if you think of Macau you probably think
about gambling and for good reason it's
the world's largest gambling hub the
region generates four times more gaming
revenue than Las Vegas making it one of
the richest places in the world but
there's more to Macau than slot machines
and roulette wheels for over 400 years
it was a Portuguese colony ancient
Chinese temples sit on streets paved
traditional Portuguese times
welcome to Macau Macau is only a one
hour ferry ride from Hong Kong and is a
gambling mecca in 2017 mainland Chinese
tourists made over 22 million trips to
Macau and spent two hundred and
seventy-three dollars per person there
are 41 casinos in the region and the
gambling industry makes up 60% of GDP
but there's more to the city you don't
have to spend your time throwing money
away in air-conditioned rooms
[Music]
this is Macau Peninsula a large section
of which is a designated UNESCO World
Heritage Site
here the blend of Portuguese and Chinese
culture is plain to see churches sit
alongside temples of fortresses bear a
mix of characteristics these are the
ruins of st. Paul's probably the most
well-known landmark in Macau it was
originally a 17th century Church and
college but was destroyed by fire in the
19th century
it features Baroque carvings of oriental
themes the blend of cultures has also
shaped the food scene
street vendors will sell you Portuguese
custard tarts and pork chop bun to Macau
version of a hamburger at the other end
of the spectrum is a launcher this
authentic Portuguese restaurant keeps
the colonial culinary history of Macau
alive
its interior design is a nod to the
area's naval history
[Music]
finally check out the view from the
Macau tower and then leap off it you can
bungy down from the platform 233 meters
above the ground sure beats walking
[Music]
you